what is the story that at the at the
audition you weren't a Star Wars
aficionado no I hadn't thanks single one
and the second to last one second to
last well alright put you off well I did
bookend it yeah exactly you followed the
whole story Chewbacca's in it I'm fun
yeah he's he's all over this one you'll
like this one
so you hadn't seen any of them and yet
you rock up for the audition and rock up
the audition and could you put that one
think it's my horse yes I was I was
going to the audition and I thought I'm
just gonna this character is an amazing
she's a revolutionary she's really cool
and the dialogue was amazing and but it
kind of said just in one of the state
directions draw it and so I was like
droid Toit
and I google droid and then nothing much
really came up with leaders pictures
there wasn't explicitly it's a robot it
wasn't an audition I was like we should
know where joyed is and I was asking my
taxi driver he's like I don't know what
a droid is and he called his family more
panicky I got and then I got to the
audition and I was like I'm just gonna
play it like a human because the chances
are it's a human because most of the
times when you audition it's a human
human and I did the audition they were
like the guys are like oh that's really
great thank you could you um tried a bit
more droid II what sort of droid you
kind of I've do you want and luckily one
of this high wrenches went like this
something I saw his hand he was like
like
I know what they were they decided they
didn't need it to be
droid here talkin in the air my boy to
my favor that way
[Music]